so whether you have a
five-thousand-dollar film or a
five-million-dollar film what do you
think the minimum budget should be for
any film in regards to marketing I mean
generally I say ten percent minimum like
bare-bones not a lots going to be able
to be done with that you know if you
have five thousand and you only have you
know five hundred dollars that you can
spend on it this is not going to go very
far I would hope that that $5,000 film
is a short and it's really a calling
card and that the majority of your
marketing is trying to get industry
attention now you know if you can get
millions of views that gets some
industry attention and that can get you
some press that all by itself you know
becomes sort of self-regulating if that
doesn't happen for most people so you're
going to be spending that 500 in
submissions sometimes two short films
too short film festivals maybe buying
Facebook ads and you can do that quite
comfortably with five hundred dollars or
less then when you get into five million
you know then that five million dollar
budget that gets to a lot more that you
can do with that and then the sky's the
limit as far as your maximum budget how
much do you think that effort putting
that money in is going to pay off in the
effort because you know you have to get
that money back before you're in profit
so so you have to be careful of not
going the other way it's way over
spending that you'll never see the the
benefit but I I give it as a rule ten
percent as the bare bare minimum
you